on en parle justement avec benjamin
morel docteur en science politique et
maître de conférences à l'université
paris 2 bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec
nous est ce que vous pensez réellement
que cette opération d'euros case âge que
c'est une opération d'euros case âge
d'anciens ministres orchestrée par le
président alors dans lesquelles vous
avez vous avez évoqué je dirais qu'il ya
trois grands cas en réalité vous avez en
effet d'anciens ministres d'anciens
secrétaires d'état on va recasé à des
postes diplomatiques
histoire d'avoir on va dire une
possibilité de rebond après une carrière
politique qui n'a pas été heureuse c'est
quelque chose qui se fait depuis très
très longtemps qui est profondément
problématique on peut en être d'accord
c'est pas nouveau ça montre que là
dessus et a pas vraiment de rupture dans
ce type de pratique qui serait incarnée
par emmanuel macron le deuxième cas
c'est celui de françois bayrou
l'enez face à quelque chose de très très
différents en réalité il s'agit
aujourd'hui de reconsolider majorité qui
est profondément fragile à l'assemblée
nationale et qui tient aujourd'hui en
grande partie grâce au modem emmanuel
macron n'a pas le luxe de se fâcher avec
françois bayrou parce que sans françois
bayrou il ne contrôle en fait que
l'assemblée nationale et donc il ne
contrôle plus la fin de son mandat
troisièmement vous avez évoqué le cas
des préfets là on est sur quelque chose
d'eux assez nouveau et qui montre la
volonté du président de la république de
vraiment avoir une emprise directe pas
seulement sur le gouvernement
et je dirais sur la partie politique de
l'état mais également sur le
fonctionnement concret des
administrations en groupant et bien ce
qu'ils pouvaient faire au sein même de
l'administration les éventuels
modération contre-pouvoir à sont au
pouvoir de l'elysée au pouvoir
présidentiel vous avez évoqué le
françois bayrou et le modem ce que ça
signifie que le modem s'inscrit dans la
macro nir oui et non c'est plus
compliqué que ça il faut comprendre il
faut voir qu'au mois de février alors
que là
public en marche avec la majorité
absolue encore à l'époque à l'assemblée
nationale ce qu'aujourd'hui elle n'a
plus ans avec l'hémorragie des députés
notamment avec la création de deux
nouveaux groupes et bien la république
en marche et débattu à l'assemblée
nationale sur des amendements sur des
bébelles parce qu'il ya des heures il ya
des députés la république en marge de
l'assemblée nationale aujourd'hui
eh bien on ne voit plus réellement qui
n'apparaissent plus comme assez
mobilisés et donc il ya une majorité
théorique mais même quand elles existent
et avait pas de majorité effective
donc à partir de là le modem qui est un
groupe discipliné qui fonctionnent assez
bien est un groupe qui devient cruciale
pour emmanuel macron parce que sans ce
groupe là vous avez des projets de loi
qui sont lancés mais si jamais ils sont
pas adoptées comme le gouvernement
aurait souhaité qu'il soit adopté et
bien emmanuel macron a deux choix soit
reconnaître qu' il ne tient plus à
politique parce qu'il n'a plus de
majorité à l'assemblée soit assumée des
textes qui ne sont pas ceux qui l'aurait
voulu évidemment c'est un pas qu'on
s'est un peu compliqué un an et demi
d'une présidentielle
donc françois bayrou est là dessus
quelqu'un qui tient réellement
aujourd'hui une carte face à une
manuelle mâcon à partir de là essayer de
calmer quelque peu ses ardeurs de lui
donner un marocain qui est un marocain
prospective c'est à dire que il y aura
pas réellement de capacité de décision
même s'il va voir s'il va y avoir une
forte exposition médiatique c'est on va
dire de bonne politique c'est plutôt
malin à savoir si françois bayrou on
sera plus docile pour cela je crois pas
que ce soit non plus tout à fait dans
son livre vous évoquez la présidentielle
la prochaine présidentielle est ce que
finalement tous et recasage n'est pas
servir les ambitions des manuels macron
en vue d'un second mandat
si on pense à françois bayrou l'un des
objectifs peut évidemment être également
qu' il ne se présente pas en cours un
emmanuel macron qui qui serait quelque
peu fragilisé par la crise économique
excepté rare c'est que françois bayrou a
longtemps et sans doute n'est-il pas
abandonné l'ambition d'être président de
la république
les autres recasage et pénicaud et
cetera là encore une fois on est dans un
cas plus classique c'est c'est sans
doute moins prégnant - pourtant
concentré et là les éventuels recasage
entre guillemets dans la préfectorale
notamment le directeur de cabinet de
richard ferrand qui est devenu préfet du
territoire de belfort
là il ya une volonté d'avoir une prise
directe de l'administration où justement
et bien pouvoir contrôler avant les
présidentielles que les décisions qui
sont celles prises par emmanuel macron
seront réellement les décisions
appliquées jusqu'au plus petit maillage
territorial
donc là on a en effet une volonté d'une
action qui sera une action plus direct
plus forte de l'exécutif pour que dans
la stratégie d' emmanuel macron et bien
il peut il assume ce qu'il a fait et ils
puissent ils puissent se gargariser de
dire qu'il a réussi à agir sur le
terrain sur concret merci à vous
benjamin morale docteur en science
politique et maître de conférences à
l'université paris xii